-Chloe, you do
so many great impressions,
and I wanted to challenge yo
to something fun.
We all want to
get in the holiday spirit,
so here's what we're gonna do.
I'd love you to start
reading the classic poem
"'Twas the Night
Before Christmas," okay?
And as you're reading, there
will be names of celebrities
that pop up onscreen, okay
So you'll keep reading
but in the voice of whoeve
comes up next.
And you could wear that scar
if you'd like to.
You don't have to.
-Ooh! Well, it does
match my outfit.
-It actually really does.
-Yeah. Holiday vibes!
-Okay, here we go. Ready?
Whenever you're ready,
you can start
with the first impression
that appears on the screen
right over there.
Ruth, can we get
some sleigh bells?
[ Sleigh bells jingling ]
All right, here we go.
-[ As Reese Witherspoon ] Okay
Ahem. Okay, 'twas the nigh
before Christmas,
when all through the house
not a creature was stirring,
not even a fierce
little mouse, y'all!
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
[ Bell dings ]
-[ Normal voice ] Okay.
[ As Drew Barrymore ]
The children were nestled
all snug in their amazing beds
while visions of
the most gorgeous sugarplums
danced in their head.
[ Bell dings ]
-[ Laughing ]
-[ Normal voice ] Oh!
Okay, this one.
-Margaret Thatcher.
-You got the teeth -- the teeth.
[ As Margaret Thatcher ]
When out on the lawn,
there arose
an unfavorable clatter,
I sprang from my bedchambers
to see what was the matter
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God!
[ Bell dings ]
-[ Normal voice ] Oh, good
I have to pretend this is
a shawl for Nicole Kidman.
-All right.
-Okay.
[ Breathes deeply ]
[ As Nicole Kidman ] Away to the
window I jumped like a 'roo,
tore open the shutters,
and [laughs]
oh, my God what a view.
-Oh, my God.
[ Bell dings ]
-[ Normal voice ] Oh.
All right, here we go.
[ As Phoebe Waller-Bridge
'Twas a little old chap
so cheeky and quick,
I knew in a moment
he must be St. Nick.
-[ Laughing ]
[ Bell dings ]
-[ As Timothée Chalamet ]
Uh, he -- he had a broad fac
and a, uh, little round bell
that shook when he laughed
like a bowl of jelly.
[ Laughs ]
Nah, nah, nah.
I'm sorry, Nick.
[ Bell dings ]
-[ Normal voice ] Ah, okay
This one's fun.
Ah, well, you know,
to get into Meryl Streep,
I kind of have to adjust my hair
a little bit.
[ As Meryl Streep ]
Ah, well, you know...
But I heard him exclaim,
as he drove out of sight,
Meryl Christmas to all
and to all a good night!
-Chloe Fineman, everybody!
That is how you do it
right there!
Chloe Fineman -- Check her out
on "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend, which is all new
with host Timothée Chalame
and musical guest
Bruce Springsteen
and the E Street band.
We're gonna hear a lot fro
Chloe Fineman, everybody.